bonjour je m'appelle Léa j'ai pas depuis
trois quatre ans j'ai la maladie de
Charcot et à cause de ça pleine grâce à
ça j'ai décidé de me lancer et créer un
livre qui s'appelle
maladie peut vraiment que tu vas
basculer ça me touche au début
j'étais étudiante et je me suis
réveillée pour la nuit avec les crampes
dans les jambes dans une première tente
pour moi c'était quelque chose un peu
bizarre mais j'ai pas pensé que c'était
quelque chose de grave moi je suis je me
sens seule pour que pendant ah non j'ai
vécu avec les symptômes ça me rend
compte que c'était profond de moi je
savais que j'avais cette maladie
malheureusement et même si j'avais gardé
l'espoir que j'avais peut-être autre
chose
quelque chose qui est déjà qui existe
sur le portable souvent de boire avec
iPhone c'est que j'ai cette commande
vocale sur l'écran tout est chiffrés
donc si je dis
tu es où
donc
dépendance et je peux plus faire comme
je veux donc c'est
c'est pas mal c'est chouette
qu'on va faire beaucoup avec les yeux
donc c'est la commande oculaire on dit
ça comme ça ça existe la technologie
pour faire
diriger une chaise roulante motorisée
avec les yeux toi aussi hyper apprécié
lorsque ça existe en fait et on peut
imaginer à quel point ça porte
j'aurais jamais imaginé avoir eu
l'occasion la chance le besoin de faire
des trucs pareils comme écrire j'ai créé
une association qui s'appelle
30 secondes donc parler c'est très
important parce que c'est vrai
aujourd'hui cette maladie ça fait partie
de mon identité mais c'est pas que ça
c'est soit
pour manger puis que j'ai perdu mon
appétit en fait
je pouvais très bien pas manger toute la
journée pour moi c'est très bizarre
parce qu'avant j'étais assez grande
pas très envie
donc c'est à dire qu'on passe des
moments ensemble comme tout le monde
pour moi je suis plus marié que les
dents il y a quand même des choses voilà
qu'on fait au quotidien ou je suis là
pour soutenir la main verte
le traitement que vous recevez aux
Etats-Unis c'est pas possible en France
il existe pas encore malheureusement non
il faut être là c'est l'entreprise qui
est dans les salles de Texas qui produit
des
cellules souches donc c'est des cellules
très régulatrices qui viennent de la
connaissance est produite
et auteurs
Colombia
donc je suis la patiente qui résul le
plus c'est cellule très régulatrice au
monde je crois et c'est très difficile à
dire
c'est ça bien fonctionné ou pas parce
que je suis la seule patiente en fait
donc une personne
moi j'estime que
ça lui défait parce que c'était très
rapide au début et après que j'ai
commencé cette traitement ça énormément
ralenti
on essaie de faire
[Musique]
déjà d'avoir les handicaps c'est pas
il y a plein de personnes qui habitent
avec
la
vie peut continuer de très belles avec
c'est pas parce qu'on a des soucis
qu'on peut pas voyager on peut pas aller
sortir et tout ça et j'avais pas
vraiment de but
dans la vie avant et là aujourd'hui j'ai
pas que je me battre parce que j'ai
envie d'avoir une grande avenir avec mon
mari avec mes amis avec ma famille et
pour travailler pour que ça soit
possible pour moi et pour les autres